there's been this press in this talk
that you participated here in the
bloodiest scene they're calling it the
bloodiest scene in the history of horror
films and I think they have actual
statistics to back it up in this next
film is that true iPad so I was told on
set it wasn't real blood obviously it
would have what if it was real blood and
it was an incredible waste of nine
hospitals had no blood they said it was
worth it yeah well they needed blood for
their help yes sorry sorry I'm so sorry
yeah your grandma's gonna go so wait so
you were it's fake blood yes but it's
4,500 gallons of fake blood and that
means that you are like you're a whole
you're you're in it you're immersed in
blood I was immersed in it I mean
basically it's it's kind of like a
mixture it's like KY jelly with with red
dye oh I've been there anyway settle
down it's not that kind of show but you
said you encouraged the director go for
it you said I did like pour as much
blood as you got oh go for it I said he
said you know what he was told telling
me about the scene and he said you know
it's only gonna go up to your chest and
it's fine I said well this is our
opportunity to really make something
crazy
let's do carry on steroids right so I
fully went in the blood which I
regretted a lot afterwards yeah yeah
I was holding like stuff out of my
eyeballs the next day right right that
could have been your eyeball you don't
know something around well is it true
that you do an impression of Jessica
covered in the blood yeah well and set
up this impression for me yeah
I'm gonna put a nickel in and there you
go all right
know what happens when they would pour
the blood on Jessica it was incredibly
cold and so when that happened we knew
that was our time that we were about to
shoot any minute right so we would hear
this sound which was
[Laughter]